دون كهرباء وفي مراسم اكتسمت بالبساطه
احتفل الاوكرانيون من الارثودوكس بعيد
الميلاد
صلوات وترانيم دون اي حديث او عظم كما هي
الحال في المذاهب الاخرى اميره الشموع على
امل ان يحل السلام في عيد شهد خلافا بين
كنائس المذهب الواحد في البلاد بشان موعده
[موسيقى]
مذهب ومرجعيه في اوكرانيا
منذ عده سنوات دعت مرجعيه كليب الى تغيير
موعد العيد الى يوم الخامس والعشرين من
ديسمبر الامر الذي اثار حفيظه البطريركيه
موسكو التي تعتمد السابع من يناير موعد
للعيد
عن هذا الخلاف استوقفنا نكيتا الذي كان
يحضر لشراء حاجات عشيه الاحتفال ليقضيه مع
اقاربه
حتى من هو الان في مكان الامن لا يعرف ان
كان احد من احد سيستطيع الاحتفاله او انه
سيبقى على قيد الحياه يوم العيد
على الرغميه من عدم وجود مظاهر الاحتفال
في الشوارع والساحات العامه
فان البعض اقاموا طقوس العيد
في بيت يضم عددا من العائلات كلها نازحه
بدا ان بهجه العيد اتخذت لنفسها مكان هنا
الهدف هو التفكير في القادم كما يقولون
وكل الاماني ستكون معقوده على انتهاء
الحرب
[موسيقى]
تطبيقات لابد ان نذكر الله في هذا اليوم
وان نحاول ان نكون متفائلين وايجابيين
الكل محتاج هنا للتنفيذ عن الالم والتوتر
والخوف من المستقبل الغامض لكن لا باس من
بعض الفرح واستعاده ذكريات العيد الجميله
واحد لكن كيف رفضت ذلك وقالت ان روسيا
تريد الظهور بمظهر الراغب في السلام وهي
التي قصفت العشرات من دون العباده
ترى فئه من المواطنين الاوكرانيين
الارثوذكس في تغيير موعد الاحتفال بعيد
الميلاد تعبيرا عن رفضهم لسلطه وسياسه
الكنيسه روسيه التي يعتبرونها معاديه
لبلادهم بينما لا يزال اخر هنا موالينا
للكنيسه في موسكو خلاف يعمل الكثيرون هنا
لا يؤثر على جواهر العيد المتمثل بالحفاظ
على الروابط العائليه التي يقوم عليها
المجتمع الاوكراني عمر الحاج الجزيره من
مدينه